no te dan vuelve a estar en pie el marco
del edificio ya fue estabilizado
ahora comienza la reconstrucción tres
años después de que ardiera en llamas
desde cirujanos de árboles hasta
pintores múltiples artesanos de toda
francia están usando sus habilidades
para restaurar la catedral y devolverle
su antigua gloria
las obras datan de los siglos 17 y 18
aunque al principio no estaba claro si
los monumentos al óleo sobre lienzo
podrían sobrevivir al incendio
restaurar los cuadros es una mezcla una
mezcla de barniz con un poco de
repintado algunas de las pinturas han
quedado muy oscuras por las llamas al
principio pensé que no podían ser
restauradas pero no fue así de hecho
están libres de los contaminantes del
incendio off esos son de presión
la restauración de las pinturas llevará
dos años tiempo exacto para la
reapertura de la catedral
en el resto de francia se están talando
árboles antiguos en los bosques de todo
el país la madera se utilizará para
reconstruir la aguja de notredame que se
diseñará tal y como se hizo
originalmente en el siglo 19 lo que
significa que se necesitarán 1000 roble
y la catedral también va a recuperar su
voz los ocho mil tubos del gran órgano
se están limpiando
mientras los artesanos perfecciona la
reconstrucción de su interior
se trata de la experiencia para nosotros
es imponente
se han prometido unos 845 millones de
euros de donantes privados y
empresariales para la restauración de
nuestra dama que debe terminar a tiempo
para su primer servicio completo
previsto para el 16 de abril de 2024
[Música]